Après avoir testé les jeux
les plus rageants de la planète,
il revient aujourd'hui pour vous
prouver une fois de plus qu'il n'a pas
trop de skill !
Ok, le malaise, on arrête !
Yo tout l'monde c'est Squeezie, aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur Blood Dungeon,
c'est un petit jeu rageant. Le principe est très simple :
c'est plein de niveaux et on n'a que 10 secondes
Pour faire chaque niveau. Les mecs se sont dit : "on va faire un jeu hyper dur,
et en plus, pour casser les couilles, ils auront que 10 secondes pour le faire !"
Quelle bonne idée !
Nouvelle partie, je n'ai pas encore eu l'occasion de le tester,
on va voir si c'est si difficile que ça !
"YOLO mode", j'sais pas c'que c'est mais on va faire le mode normal !
Ok, premier level...
Ok, c'est passé, deuxième level...
Oook, c'est passé, troisième level... *rires*
On a jamais enchaîné autant !
Ah, on peut tomber dans le vide ! Merde, ok ! Merde ! 'Tin si on pouvait sauter mon gars
on prendrait un raccourci de malade !
Mais on peut pas le faire, donc on va arrêter de se faire rêver !
Ook, c'est quoi ce piège ? No fucking problem, we gonna let it pass and gonna through !
Yes, I'm billingual ! Ok ! Ah bat... Ah mais ils me suivent ?! Ok, here we go,
j'ai compris, clac clac clac et ouii !
Ok, c'est quoi ça ?
'Tin je bugue tellement c'est impressionnant !
Quand je pense, on est jamais allé aussi...
Oh les bâtards, c'est lent !
Maintenant, yeah !
C'est la totale ! Ok,
ça se complique mais rien de paniquant...
Attends, là je panique pour rien là... Mais c'est quoi ça ?! Mon cerveau il bug !
Comment t'es censé passer ça mec ?
*Aah !* Mais c'est trop dur mec ! On va y aller en mode YOLO !
Ok. On va y aller en mode tranquillou, tranquillou... Steuplé... Voilà ! Ok.
En fait c'qu'est dur c'est de passer ça là ! *Aah !*
Ça va trop vite mec ! Oh non, on était tellement loin ! On était dans le turfu,
on était avec Booba, regarde dans son clip, j'suis dedans !
Oh lalalala ! C'était d'une beauté, c'était d'une bonté ! Bah là y a juste à... Ah bâtard !
J'pense faut aller là-bas en fait... Voilà, voilà, voilà...
D'accord. Là on descend, là faut y aller vite, et on s'en sort, tranquillement !
Ça c'est pas très dur ça... Merde !
YOLO, on a plus le temps... Non !
Là ! Oui monsieur ! Aucune panique à avoir !
Ok là on peut paniquer ! Alors ça ça va être hyper chiant... Maintenant !
Oh làlàlàlà, mais quel timming extraordinaire ! Oh putain c'est chiant ça, putain c'est chiant !
Oh mais c'est impossible, mec, c'est impossible !
Ah ok, fallait le faire dès le début en fait !
Ok ! I understood you know !
Heu, clac, tu t'barres, tu t'barres...
Bah oui nan mais là attend,
vous m'avez pris pour un enfant ?! Vous m'avez pris pour Théo ?
Ok j'ai compris, il faut faire clac, clac,
clac, clac... Ok au revoir !
Oh lalalala ! Comment, vous a vu, on a semé la zizanie ?! J'ai pas entendu ça
depuis dix années et si on...
*Youuhou !*
Nan mais attend, mais là, là on est chaud bouillant !
Ça dégage, et on y va !
Voilà, tranquillement ! Ohlàlà, là on va compter sur la chatte, c'est parti !
J'invoque la chatte !
Ohlàlà comment j'ai compris, vous avez vu la technique... Et y a un interrupteur, fait chier !
Oh nan fait chier !
Comment tu veux aller chopper l'interrupteur, j'comprends pas... ?
Ohlàlà, alors là ! Je sais pas comment j'ai fait ! Je ne sais pas...
Est-ce que c'est la fin du jeu ?! Non ?? Non.
Ouah, faut être précis de ouf, y a des pics partout sur les côtés !
Ah, ça tryhard ! Quand y a la langue qu'est sortie, croyez-moi, c'est que ça tryhard de ouf !
Alors là, va falloir réfléchir...
Ok...
Bah voilà, tout simplement ! Pas l'temps de réfléchir... *Aaah !*
J'ai compris les gars, à une main regard... ok.
Voilà ! Voilà, c'était tendu mais... *Ooh !*
Allez on passe la glace, aucun problème, regardez on fait ça en speedrun...
Pff, easy !
Go... fuck.
J'ai pas fait exprès, j'vais pas faire le mec !
'Tin c'est vrai qu'on a que 10 secondes, on a tendence à l'oublier mais mine de rien faut aller très très vite pour gagner.
Ah, y a combien de têtes à moi là mec sans déconner ?!
Ooook on est bon !
Ah, et là c'est du vrai sol ! Oh les enfoirés !
Là on est à l'abri. On temporise...
On est bon ! Voilà, on est passé, on continue, la laser on s'en bat les couilles !
On conti...
Ok. Les gars là j'suis en train de perdre ma volonté de, de gagner...
Par contre j'ai toujours ma liberté de penser, Florent Pagny c'est pour toi, on t'aime !
Nan mais mec c'est chaud !
Faut que j'me serve du bloc comme appui pour le laser, mais c'est impossible !
Nan mais c'est... Je vous jure, ça n'passera jamais, c'est sûr !
J'en ai marre, j'en ai marre, j'en ai marre, j'suis en train de péter un CÂBLE ! Comment on passe ?! Ok en fait j'ai compris,
la technique à faire en fait c'est pas ça, c'est ça ! Faut juste se baisser comme ça il bloque le laser,
et on peut passer ! Putain qu'est-ce que j'étais con !
Mais vous êtes sérieux là les gars ?! Calmez-vous avec vos lasers mon gars ! Y a plus de laser là qu'en boite de nuit !
"En boite de nuit" vous avez remarqué hein ?! Bah ouais j'ai 80 piges ouais, c'est quoi le problème...
WAOUH, ça part en couille !
Ok on passe, ça c'était easy ! Alors, il se passe quoi là ? Oh c'est horrible, ça c'est horrible parce qu'en fait,
faut aller appuyer le bouton qu'y a là, pour ensuite se barrer...
GOOOOOO !
Go-gadgeto con !
OH ! Oh oui, oh oui, oh oui, oh oui !
Est-ce que c'est la fin, est-ce que c'est la fin ?
Est-ce qu'on est les boss du Youtube Game ?
C'est faux !
Ok c'est nouveau, oh ça me plaît pas !
Le mec il les synchronise parfaitement de manière à désynchroniser ton cerveau...
D'accord. C'est fait !
Maintenant ! Fuck !
Oh le YOLO-mode ! YOLO-mode activé !
Ah, c'est tellement à la chatte mon gars ! Très simple, très très simple,  pour le moment
j'arrive même plus à parler mec tellement j'suis concentré... Ooh !
YOLO-style, bitch... Ok.
YOLO bitch, OUIII !
Nan mais mec t'es sérieux là ?! Faut, hé ok, faut feinter pour qu'il tombe dans le vide !
Nan mais les mecs ils s'arrêtent plus quoi !
Mais comment... ? Le bloc il doit tomber dans le vide mais coment je fais pour l'attirer dans le vide ?
Ah bah voilà, ok j'ai compris, faut que j'le ramène, viens... Ah mais nan, il m'a pas suivi !
Ah l'batard, ok, en plus il me poursuit ! Attend, c'est dur, vous avez compris ou pas ?
En fait, lui faut le bloquer là, lui j'vais l'chercher et là faut que je trace parce qu'il me poursuit l'batAAAh !
OUI, OUI, OUI, je dis oui !
Mon gars, si on arrive au bout d'ce jeu c'est tellement un truc de ouf !
Allez allez mon gars ça passe, j'ai p... Et putain ! Regardez, ça, c'est qu'on appelle du skill, attention...
Ohlàlà, comment je suis happy mon gars !
OOOH, calmez-vous ! Fuckin' calm down, ooh !
Nan mais mec, ça ne s'arrêtera jamais ! J'ai juste envie de finir ce jeu et de m'la péter,
laissez-moi !
WHAT ?
On la feinte ! Comment on craint rien ni personne c'est un truc de malade !
Attend, comment on fait là ?
Nan mais comment tu fais là ? Ah mon avis, faut le mener en bourrique, et ensuite...
OH NOOON !
YES, YEES ! Ah nan, c'est encore plus dur ! Les mecs, j'en peut plus...
Regardez le level, quoi ! Y a trop de trucs mec !
J'comprends plus comment faire,
j'comprends plus rien !
Nan mais mec, c'est c'est... Là, là tu peux plus là,
Là j'y arrive plus là... C'est, mon cerveau il lâche, il dit "nan fuck, fuck-toi Lucas !"
Si quelqu'un comprend quelque chose, qu'il like la vidéo ! Voilà, y aura aucun, aucun like !
On va y arriver, mec, on va y arriver, si on y arrive on est les master de Youtube !
NOOON !
C'EST LA FIN ?
On a terminé le jeu ?!
Nan...
Abonnez-vous !